Queridos amigos, amigas de VisualPolitik,
el Plan Motosierra del gobierno libertario
de Javier Milei está en marcha.
El nuevo presidente ha llegado al gobierno
con la intención clara de cambiar la Argentina.
Nada de gradualismo ni de tiempos de espera.
Los cambios ya están llegando.
(0:09 Son todas leyes que
0:12 se derogan, bueno obviamente si se quiere
0:15 hacer no, y después acá tenemos el
pilón
0:18 de las leyes que se
0:21 modifican)
En el ocaso de 2023, el día 20 de diciembre,
el gobierno del presidente Javier Gerardo
Milei publicó el Decreto 70/2023. Un decreto
que nació con carácter de urgencia y con
el que de la noche a la mañana derogaron
y modificaron más de 300 regulaciones económicas
y administrativa. De golpe y porrazo. Hablamos
de una de las aventuras políticas más trepidantes
de la historia argentina.
(9:40 En el día de
9:42 hoy he firmado un decreto de necesidad
y
9:45 urgencia para comenzar a destrabar este
9:47 andamiaje jurídico institucional opresor
9:50 que ha destruido nuestro
9:54 país)
De esta forma, en vísperas de la Navidad,
el regalo de Milei para los argentinos fue
poner en marcha la demolición de gran parte
del sistema socioeconómico del país Gaucho.
Porque, amigos, al decreto urgente tenemos
que sumar la conocida como “Ley Ómnibus”.
Hablamos de un documento que el gobierno argentino
envió al Congreso, con más de 180 páginas
y 664 artículos. Un documento que nació
con la idea de que el legislativo le reconozca
al gobierno la capacidad de promulgar directamente
un montón de cambios dada la situación de
emergencia pública que vive el país. Una
pretensión que, por supuesto, he levantado
muchas críticas entre la oposición.
Si tenemos en cuenta tanto el decreto inicial
como la ley ómnibus, hablamos de un gigantesco
proceso de liberalización económica que
se ha presentado cuando el presidente argentino
no llevaba ni un mes en el poder.
[Vamos, que más que plan motosierra casi
que podríamos conocerlo mejor como el plan
turbosierra].
Sea como sea esto ha hecho que en VisualPolitik
nos hagamos unas cuantas preguntas:
¿Cómo de amplio es realmente este plan de
transformación? ¿Qué puede suponer exactamente
para la Argentina? ¿Qué postura tienen los
sindicatos y la oposición?
Pues todo esto y más lo vamos a ver a continuación.
Así que, ya sabéis, ¡Gasolina, motor en
marcha y arranquemos!
Lo primero de todo, para poder comprender
el auténtico alcance y la profundidad de
las medidas tomadas por Javier Milei, tenemos
que sobrevolar algunos conceptos jurídicos
del país albiceleste.
Y es que, veréis, lo que firmó el presidente
libertario no es un simple decreto, sino un
DECRETO DE NECESIDAD DE URGENCIA.
Este es un instrumento que está recogido
en la propia Constitución argentina, y que
le permite al gobierno aprobar o derogar por
sí mismo, normas con rango de ley en caso
de urgencia, disminuyendo así las capacidades
del Congreso.
A ver, lógicamente no es un que el gobierno
puede gobernar en base de decretos saltándose
al Congreso, sino que estás son herramientas
para situaciones de emergencia. Concretamente,
esto es lo que dice el artículo 99 de la
Constitución.
C1(“Solamente cuando circunstancias excepcionales
hicieran imposible seguir los trámites ordinarios
previstos por esta Constitución para la sanción
de las leyes, y no se trate de normas que
regulen materia penal, tributaria, electoral
o de régimen de los partidos políticos,
[el presidente] podrá dictar decretos por
razones de necesidad y urgencia”. Artículo
99 Constitución de la República Argentina
(1994) – Atribuciones del presidente de
la Nación)
Ahora bien, como solemos por aquí, hecha
la ley, hecha la trampa.
La Constitución no aclara que es exactamente
una “circunstancia excepcional”, y, claro,
ya sabéis que los políticos [por muy nuevos
y diferentes que sean] siempre suelen saber
como torcer el sentido común a su favor.
En este caso, la lógica detrás del anuncio
EW de Milei y su decreto es que Argentina
enfrenta una crisis económica absolutamente
excepcional que justifica la toma de medidas
drásticas y aceleradas. Es por eso que el
gobierno se vio obligado a usar el decreto
de urgencia. Fijaos.
C2(“Es imprescindible adoptar medidas que
permitan superar la situación de emergencia
creada por las excepcionales condiciones económicas
y sociales que la Nación padece, especialmente,
como consecuencia de un conjunto de decisiones
intervencionistas.” Decreto 70/2023: Bases
para la reconstrucción de la economía argentina)
Ojo, de todas formas, no es que el Congreso
aquí no pinte nada. Para nada. Lo cierto
es que el poder legislativo mantiene la capacidad
de vetar cualquier decreto de urgencia.
Todo esto, por cierto, no es nada nuevo para
el sistema político argentino. De hecho,
el gobierno de Carlos Saúl Menem en los 90s
hizo un uso más que intensivo de este instrumento
para poder avanzar así con su ambicioso su
programa económico.
Un programa orientado también fundamentalmente
a la desregulación de la economía. [Ya sabéis
que hablamos de Argentina, donde eso de liberalizar
la economía suele tener pocos amigos en el
Congreso.]
(1:04 A partir de hoy rompemos la telaraña
de
1:08 un estado prebendario asfixiante y
1:12 arbitrario que trabó la vida productiva
1:15 nacional con un conjunto de innecesarias
1:18 regulaciones
+
2:24 voy a pasar a enumerar
2:28 de un modo claro y conciso cada una de
2:31 las principales disposiciones que el
2:34 poder ejecutivo nacional ha
2:36 instrumentado mediante un decreto de
2:39 necesidad y urgencia imprescindible para
2:42 asegurar el marco de estabilidad y bien
común)
La cuestión es que la lógica de “gobernar
por decreto” siempre tiene ciertos tintes
super-presidencialistas y suele generar la
duda de si realmente los gobiernos no se sobrepasan
con ellos. Aunque, como vimos, tanto el Congreso
como, en última instancia, la Corte Suprema,
pueden limitar a su alcance e, incluso, su
propia vigencia.
Sea como sea, la cuestión es que este recurso
de Milei ha levantado muchísimas críticas
que cuestionan su legitimidad.
[Si os parece en los comentarios, podéis
decirnos que os parece que Milei haya comenzado
así la oleada de cambios que ha preparado
para el país. No se, creo que puede ser un
debate, la mar de interesante.]
Dicho lo cual, ahora sí, ha llegado el momento
de echar un vistazo a los cambios.
¡Atentos!
(T1: SALUDEN AL ESTADO… QUE SE VA)
Si os parece, vamos a empezar por lo más
básico: las tan temidas privatizaciones.
Es decir, vender empresas públicas, que la
verdad, suelen tener más agujeros que un
queso gruyer.
Pues bien, en Argentina esto supone un esfuerzo
titánico, entre otras cosas, porque las “empresas
públicas del estado” no son realmente compañías
mercantiles al uso, sino que tienen un estatus
especial: son Sociedades del Estado, una categoría
especial que establece que el único dueño
posible es precisamente el propio estado y
que hace que sus trabajadores en la práctica
sean básicamente trabajadores públicos.
Prácticamente funcionarios.
Por eso, el primer paso para privatizar estas
empresas pasa por convertirlas en sociedades
anónimas, con todo lo que ello conlleva.
Este fue precisamente uno de los puntos clave
del decreto de urgencia de Milei.
(11:14 Ocho, derogación de
11:17 la normativa que impide la privatización
11:19 de las empresas públicas. Nueve, derogación
11:22 del régimen de sociedades del
11:25 Estado. Diez, transformación de todas
las
11:28 empresas del estado en sociedades
11:29 anónimas para su posterior privatización.)
Claro que una vez hecho este cambio, ahora
toca lo más difícil: encontrar unE comprador
que esté dispuesto a quedarse con empresas,
que, por lo general, son deficitarias, poco
productivas, con trabajadores cabreados y
con el riesgo para colmo de que en el futuro
un gobierno de otro color pueda volver a cambiar
las reglas de juego.
Pensado lo bien, entre los sindicatos, la
oposición, las protestas y los beneficios
laborales, privatizar empresas en la Argentina
puede llegar a ser tan fácil como enseñar
a bailar tango o aun oso polar. Y eso por
no hablar de los compradores, que seguro,
seguro, se terminarán haciendo una pregunta:
¿en qué lío me estoy metiendo?
Pues bien, entre las empresas a las que pronto
le colgarán el cartel de “se vende” tenemos
la YPF, que es en cierto modo una excepción…
Aunque eso sí, con algunos matices. Desde
el gobierno la nacionalizara en 2012, esta
compañía ha mejorado sus números gracias
a Vaca Muerta, pero ahora el estado puede
tener que pagar la friolera de 16.000 millones
de dólares en indemnizaciones. Lo que hace
que la operación haya sido una auténtica
ruina. La pregunta es, ¿tendrán que asumir
los compradores este enorme pago?
N1(31 de marzo de 2023. Claves para entender
el fallo contra la Argentina por la expropiación
de YPF – Una jueza de los Estados Unidos
le dio la razón al demandante y señaló
que fueron perjudicados por la estatización
de 2012, al no realizar una oferta por las
acciones que poseían en la compañía. La
magistrada aceptó el cálculo de intereses
reclamado, por lo que especialistas estiman
que el país deberá pagar cerca de US$ 16
mil millones de indemnización. Chequeado)
Luego, otra empresa que parece va a ser privatizada
próximamente es Aerolíneas Argentinas, que
cuenta con uno de los sindicatos más radicalizados
de todo el país.
N2(21 de noviembre de 2023: "Si se quiere
cargar Aerolíneas Argentinas, nos va a tener
que matar": amenaza a Milei y posterior marcha
atrás del principal sindicalista aeronáutico.
Clarín)
Pero ojo, porque el Estado no solo está pensando
en deshacerse de las empresas públicas, sino
que también acabará con los beneficios que
tienen algunos sectores productivos: hablamos,
por ejemplo, de bonificaciones fiscales, créditos
a tipos ventajosos, subsidios o restricciones
de entrada al sector, entre otros.
Pues bien, eso se acabó.
La idea es que a partir de ahora todas las
empresas compitan con las mismas reglas. Ni
privilegios ni ventajas.
(11:09 Seis, derogación de la ley de promoción
11:10 Industrial. Siete, derogación de la
ley de
11:14 promoción comercial
+
11:57 Quince, derogación de las acciones
de los
11:59 ingenios azucareros tienen en materia
de
12:02 producción azucarera. Dieciséis, liberación
del
12:05 régimen jurídico aplicable del sector
12:08 vitivinícola)
Eso sí, todas las agrupaciones empresariales
respaldaron el cambio… Sobre todo seducidos
por una promesa de Milei: llevar a cabo una
gran reforma laboral.
Y, amigos, ese pulso ya ha comenzado. Atentos.
(T2: ¿EN LA CUEVA DEL LEÓN?)
Queridos amigos, aquí en VisualPolitik ya
os hemos hablado varias veces del inmenso
poder que tienen los sindicatos argentinos.
Durante años, si los sindicatos querían
en la Argentina, no se movía ni un dedo.
Claro que en los últimos años ese poder
incontestable, casi “extorsivo”, ha comenzado
a ser duramente criticado, especialmente por
dos cosas: Porque los sindicatos se han convertido
básicamente en un brazo político del peronismo
y por su en muchos casos extravagante tren
de vida a todo trapo. Y eso es lo que explica
que su popularidad se haya desplomado hasta
convertirse con mucha diferencia en la institución
peor valorada de todas. Fijaos.
Ni el FMI, ni los bancos, ni los medios de
comunicación suscitan tanto rechazo. Hablamos
de que 7 de cada 10 argentinos tienen una
mala o muy mala imagen de los sindicatos.
Algo que por supuesto le facilita muchos las
cosas a Milei. Cuanto menos populares sean
los sindicatos, mejor que mejor para poder
llevar a cabo su ambiciosa reforma laboral:
De momento, con el decreto de urgencia se
han ampliado los periodos de prueba para nuevos
empleados, se han introducido nuevos mecanismos
voluntarios de indemnización por despido
y cosas por el estilo.
Con todo, el verdadero golpe de efecto viene
con la suspensión de los conocidos como “bloqueos”
sindicales.
Y que veréis, en Argentina, cuando un sindicato
quería presionar a una empresa para conseguir
nuevos beneficios laborales o una mejora salarial
una medida habitualmente utilizada era la
de bloquear las entradas y salidas de los
centros de trabajo, forzando con ello la paralización
de la actividad productiva, ojo, quisieran
o no los empleados de la propia empresa.
Que era lo que explicaba noticias como estas:
N3(16 de julio de 2020: El sindicato de Camioneros
de Moyano bloquea depósitos de Mercado Libre
y peligra la entrega de productos. Infobae)
N4(19 de octubre de 2023: SanCor alertó por
un bloqueo sindical que pone en riesgo 3 millones
de litros de leche. Perfil)
N5(21 de noviembre de 2023: Santa Cruz: por
un bloqueo gremial las pesqueras están paradas
y las mineras amenazan con irse a operar a
Chile. La Nación)
Pues bien, todas estas noticias son… Historia.
El Decreto de Urgencia aprobado por Milei
ha establecido que este tipo de acciones son
ilegales y sancionables.
A partir de ahora en la Argentina será una
falta grave cualquier acción que afecte a
la libertad de trabajar de los empleados que
no quieran sumarse a una huelga o cualquier
acción que impida u obstruya el acceso a
las empresas o, por supuesto, cause algún
daño.
Por supuesto, como os podéis imaginar, esto
ha hecho que los grandes gremios sindicales
pongan el grito en el cielo. Según ellos,
se está “criminalizando el derecho a huelga”...
Lo que les ha llevado a convocar una huelga
general el 24 de enero.
[Aunque, ¿qué queréis qué os diga? Lo
único que se ha hecho es no criminalizar
que un trabajador decida trabajar si no está
de acuerdo con una huelga. Lo que, por cierto,
parece un derecho esencial, ¿no os parece?]
Eso sí, por ahora, la Cámara Nacional de
Apelaciones del Trabajo de Argentina ha dictado
la suspensión de la sección del decreto
que aborda las reformas laborales, dejando
la definición final en manos de la Corte
Suprema.
(pausa)
Luego, otro actor que también está siendo
clave en medio de toda la tensión que se
está desatando svon los denominados “Movimientos
Sociales”. ¿Y qué son los movimientos
sociales? Pues básicamente organizaciones
que pretenden aglutinar a los beneficiaros
de los planes sociales, como los subsidios
por desempleo o la Asignación Universal por
Hijo.
Estas organizaciones exigen cada dos por tres
aumentos en los pagos y más planes sociales.
¿Cómo lo hacen? Pues con protestas y cortes
en las principales arterias viales del país,
haciendo especial énfasis en los accesos
a la capital, a Buenos Aires.
Pues bien, ahora el gobierno ha comunicado
que la participación en esta clase de actividades
ilegales se sancionará con la pérdida del
plan social o el subsidio de todos aquellos
que corten las vías públicas.
(0:12 Informamos que todos
0:15 aquellos que hayan promovido instigado
0:18 organizado o participado de los cortes
0:21 perderán todo tipo de diálogo con el
0:23 Ministerio de capital humano
+
1:17 Los únicos que no van a
1:20 cobrar el plan son los que vayan a la
1:22 marcha y corten la calle, ya lo dijo
el
1:24 presidente, el que corta no cobra)
Queridos amigos, amigas, durante meses se
puso en duda que Javier Milei podría mantener
la gobernabilidad en un país acostumbrado
a las protestas masivas. Pues bien, por ahora,
el Presidente ya ha mostrado sus cartas:
Se acabó eso de agitar las calles y paralizar
por la fuerza el país.
Y, amigos, todo esto ha ocurrido en poco más
de un mes en el gobierno, y con las fiestas
de Navidad y Año nuevo de por medio. Ya os
dije antes que el nuevo gobierno ha llegado
con ganas de jugar e `l partido.
El caso es que ahora la oposición está atrincherada
en el Congreso, un lugar donde los libertarios
han comenzado a librar la madre de todas las
batallas.
El gobierno argentino necesita, en primer
lugar, que el parlamento no anule el decreto
de urgencia, y en segundo lugar, que apruebe
la ley ómnibus,
La pregunta es, ¿será esto posible? Pues…
Atentos.
(T3: LA MADRE DE TODAS LAS BATALLAS)
El paquete de medidas anunciadas por Milei
en el decreto de urgencia es tan amplió,
que aquí solo hemos visto algunos puntos
muy concretos.
Casi que podemos decir que el decreto le arruinó
las fiestas navideñas no solo a la oposición,
sino también a todos los juristas del país:
abogados, jueces y todo tipo de expertos legales.
[Me da que para el peronismo Milei se convirtió
en el autentico Grinch!
En este sentido, gran parte de la validez
del decreto de urgencia quedará en manos
de la Corte Suprema, que en las próximas
semanas seguramente se pronunciará sobre
muchos de sus puntos.
N6(21 de diciembre de 2023; Comenzó la batalla
judicial por la vigencia del DNU de Javier
Milei: se presentó el primer amparo. Piden
su nulidad “por constituir una desviación
de poder y un abuso de derecho público, por
violar el principio republicano, la división
de poderes, la democracia, el principio de
reserva de ley y los derechos colectivos de
la ciudadanía argentina a la participación
en la dirección de los asuntos públicos
directamente o a través de sus representantes”.
Clarín)
N7(26 de diciembre de 2023: Los antecedentes
de la Corte Suprema son adversos para el megadecreto
de Javier Milei. El máximo tribunal tiene
un criterio muy restrictivo para convalidar
esta facultad del Poder Ejecutivo; debe establecerse
un auténtico estado de necesidad y urgencia
y una imposibilidad legislativa. La Nación)
Ahora bien, al margen de todo este asunto
de la judicialización del decreto, la prioridad
del Congreso argentino es analizar la Ley
“Ómnibus”; una ley que sirve como complemento
al decreto y que pone su atención en otras
muchas reformas de gran calibre. Repasemos
si os parece las principales propuestas incorporadas
por el gobierno de Milei a este proyecto de
Ley:
Por ejemplo, hablamos, de una REFORMA ELECTORAL,
que planteaba eliminar las PASO; esto, las
Primarias Abiertas Simultaneas y Obligatorias.
Esto dejará en manos de cada partido decidir
la fórmula para escoger a sus candidatos.
Luego, además, se plantea instaurar en todo
el país una modalidad de circunscripciones
uninominales para la elección de Diputados
Nacionales, donde las provincias menos pobladas
tendrían menos representantes.
·
Por otro lado, la ley contempla una amnistía
fiscal para todos aquellos que buscaron esconder
sus ingresos durante el gobierno de Alberto
Fernández. Esta medida permitirá regularizar
hasta US$100.000 en efectivo, inmuebles o
criptomonedas sin tener que pagar impuestos.
·
Se reforma también el esquema de la OBRA
PÚBLICA, para que los planes de infraestructura
sean financiados por fondos privados, abriendo
la posibilidad de renegociar o rescindir de
contratos en ejecución.
Se elimina la conocida como MOVILIDAD JUBILATORIA,
de tal forma que sea el Ejecutivo quien establezca
una nueva modalidad para el cálculo de los
reajustes periódicos y automáticos.
·
Se contempla la efectiva PRIVATIZACIÓN DE
41 EMPRESAS PÚBLICAS, entre ellas, la empresa
de correo público, YPF, el Banco Nación
y la empresa de telecomunicaciones del Estado.
Y también se creará un Mercado de carbono
y se establecerán controles a las emisiones.
Bien, eso es principalmente lo que contiene
la ley. Eso sí, aunque Milei prometió defender
a cabbvpa y espada sus reformas dentro del
legislativo, la bancada libertaria está en
clara minoría, lo que lógicamente la ha
obligado a tener que negociar con bloques
no peronistas para poder reunir los votos
suficientes y aprobar, al menos en la Cámara
baja, el proyecto de ley.
Y es que llegados hasta aquí, creo que todos
podemos entender la enorme, la gigantesca
dimensión que tiene la apuesta que ha hecho
Javier Milei.
En primer lugar, tenemos el decreto, que modifica
de un plumazo años de regulaciones y restricciones
a la actividad económica.
Las dudas sobre su legalidad se fundamentan
en que no existe una “necesidad de urgencia”
reconocida en el país, pero justo aquí donde
entra la ley ómnibus, que sirve -más allá
de las reformas complementarias- para que
el Congreso valide la consideración del estado
de emergencia.
Si Milei logra que la mayoría del legislativo
le otorgue ese respaldo, es prácticamente
imposible que la Corte Suprema tumbe tanto
el decreto como la propia Ley Ómnibus.
La jugada de Milei es osada: en pocas semanas
su gobierno puede tener una victoria histórica
o sufrir una gran derrota ante el legislativo
y la Corte Suprema nada más comenzar su mandato.
Sea como sea, la motosierra está en marcha,
y los libertarios ya están enseñando su
carta final en el caso de que sus planes no
salgan como esperan:
(18:21 (Periodista) En el caso de que sea
rechazado en el tiempo
18:25 ¿llamarías una consulta popular, un
plebiscito?
18:28: (Milei) Obviamente, que me expliquen,
18:31 por qué el Congreso se pone en contra
de algo que le hace bien a la gente)
Queridos amigos y amigas de VPK, nos puede
gustar más o menos lo que Milei está haciendo
y las formas que está utilizando, pero lo
cierto es que Milei está haciendo exactamente
lo que prometió: rechazar cualquier tipo
de gradualismo e ir a por todas.
¿Y sabéis qué? Incluso el propio Mauricio
Macri considera que ese enfoque era equivocado.
6:40 Lo llame gradualismo, una forma elegante
de
6:43 ocultar la debilidad política que tenía.
Cualquier cosa mandaba a la Cámara
6:48 Diputados… pedía un pollo y me mandaban
una pluma)
(4:52 Los ciudadanos de esa creencia de que
4:54 los `políticos son seres superiores
que
4:57 deben regir los destinos de cada uno
de
4:58 nosotros se desprende un amen
5:01 institucional que hace que nadie pueda
5:03 trabajar comerciar circular o educarse
5:06 sin el permiso de ellos)
Así están las cosas en Argentina… Y este
es el camino de demolición y reconstrucción
que ha planteado el nuevo presidente, conocida
ya como el león argentino.
Llegados hasta aquí ahora la pregunta es
para ti:
¿Qué opinas del plan Milei? ¿Te parece
bien intentar sacar todas las reformas de
golpe? ¿Crees que la ley ómnibus será finalmente
aprobada y Milei se saldrá con la suya?
Déjanos como siempre tus impresiones en los
comentarios y abramos debate. Y ahora, si
este vídeo te ha resultado interesante, no
olvides darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik
si es que aún no lo has hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.